ensuite même des six dj oil of et le
jeune centre la force de dany c'est que
s'il avait quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel dans les syndicats lundi
ses moulins qui va et 1 à 6 ans se
couche après l'image il n'arrête pas il
est à fond dans tout ce qui fait peur
le super u est super u et le petit
déjeuner traditionnel massa et c'est un
potage composé du coeur des poumons et
du foie de la chèvre et plein d'autres
petites choses très original tout plaqué
il a toujours autant envie de faire rire
il ya toujours ton proche des gens les
très attachant qu elle son visage fait
rire en même temps on a envie de danser
les jours
on dit que je suis choqué c'est faux
archi faux je me fiche pas mal devant
l'apparence à part mes cheveux je résous
berthier est assez proche de moi c'est
un personnage qui a beaucoup d'humanité
beaucoup de fragilité couper cette
fragilité là c'est c'est l'enfance le
clown c'est la tendresse c'est les plus
beaux personnages
ça me ressemble en tout cas bienvenue
dans la ville des verts rech attend chez
un garçon assez sensibles eux on veut
faire une carrière de
l'agent j'ai fait pas mal de cours de
danse la danse russe très difficile à
danseurs données soit nickel quoi
deux minutes de chorégraphie assez
complexe et je voulais pouvoir le faire
d'une traite en blanc
j'ai un côté très perfectionniste mais
j'étais traqueuse j'étais très très
vieux
je pense que le trac ou la fragilité
c'est très important parce que si je
l'avais pas je serai pas à ma place
j'ai passé un tournage vraiment
formidable
respire